foreign
what's going on thank you so much for
having me thanks for calling what can we
help you with
so I'm in baby step number one but I
racked up a considerable amount of debt
um throughout the pandemic including the
purchase of a new vehicle and in
listening to you guys I'm wondering if I
should just sell my car and try to buy
another one for cash yeah so tell us a
little bit about this car situation what
are you what's the vehicle would you buy
would you um it's a 2020 Ford Escape
which I use for work every day I'm it's
a great reliable vehicle I'm sure but it
is definitely nicer than what I need and
as I've been just listening to the
Ramsay show and realizing what Financial
impact it's making on my already
existing debt I've just been wondering
if it would be a better idea to
um to sell it and buy another one cash
yeah so let's break down the numbers
um what'd you spend on it
um it was
about 40.
um I've been paying
um I've paid probably about 10 000 off
so far in the last three years so about
30 30. yeah and uh if you were to sell
it today what's it worth
I don't even know
okay so that's the first thing we want
to look at because if you owe 30 on it
and if you were to sell it you know it's
they'd only give you 20 or something
like that for it we need to understand
that so that's the first thing I would
look at now let's take a look at your
income so you spent 40K on a vehicle
what's your take-home pay every month
or your yearly income however you want
it three to five thousand a month
okay yeah
a little too much car I would say on
that yeah
um any other debt do you have
got about twenty thousand dollars of
credit card debt and about 30
000 in loans yeah okay yeah we got to
get out of this car
20 000 a credit card debt 30 000 in
loans explain to me the spread on your
income you said between three to five
thousand dollars that's a big spread
help me understand that
so I'm a massage therapist and I'm in
school right now to become a physical
therapist so I don't work regular hours
I'm not on a regular salary I'm
basically just available for when my
clients need me okay and are you during
the pandemic I wasn't able to work at
all legally so that was a major impact
and part of the reason that I started
taking out loans
okay so you were just taking out loans
and credit cards to just fund your life
and not working
yes okay so do you recognize the
we're never gonna do that again ever
oh yeah ever ever ever ever ever it's a
series of horrible decisions and I'm so
glad that I decided to to try and reach
out to find some sort of a financial
advisor who pointed me to the Dave
Ramsey website awesome
um and I've been learning about how to
manage personal finances Welcome to our
crazy gang man we got you so you're
you're schooling right now is it is it
full time tell me about your school I
want to get an idea of your time
um what your time looks like I'm in
school full-time I'm working as close to
full-time as I can
um and just basically running into way
too much month at the end of my money
and just you know my credit cards they
are ranging from about 25 to 30 percent
interest each month
the payments that I'm making are not
even really making a dent I'm just
drowning yeah so the the key here the
key here is you got how to get your
income up how much school do you have
left
how much how much time until school's
done
six years wait you just started
six years I I I've been a small business
owner for 10 years and I just just
jumped back into school uh last semester
to get my
um Bachelor's in kinesiology so that I
can apply to a physical therapy program
yeah excellent all right can you are you
are you casual in this you're taking out
student loans
I've taken out student loans as well
because that's part of the loan yeah we
got it yes you gotta I hate to tell you
you gotta stop we gotta stop we gotta
stop and back up because
we you started going full steam ahead on
a good intentioned plan but with a yeah
with a bad strategy
does that make sense good intention that
you want to get your income you want to
you know get your education change
careers love that but let's do it the
right way because you are I mean like
you said you're barely making you're
making three thousand bucks a month
barely making payments on this stuff
we've got to find a way that we can go
in an order that makes sense
um right now there is a trade that or
skill set that you have that you know
how to do and you can make money on it I
I would love to see you get control of
this financial situation and then work
towards a way that you can Finance
school pay for school so that you're not
taking out student loan debt because
right now otherwise you're gonna you're
gonna wake up in six years you're gonna
owe 150 000 in addition to all this
money yeah we're not going forward like
we would not love you if we said this is
a great idea and both Jade and I have
been to a lot of college we both believe
in school and I love school that's right
but you are you are man you are you're
trying to put out a fire with a
blowtorch
yeah you got to stop the step one to
getting out of debt is stop getting in
more debt yeah that draw a line in the
sand that's no longer never again yeah
do you see what we're saying we're
coming down on your heart and I I don't
want you to think that we're squashing
your dreams we're just saying in a
minute okay yeah no I I understand and
that's why I was so I couldn't believe
that he kind of took my call because
I've been listening to your show and I
just thought man I wish I could just ask
them yeah wish I could just ask somebody
look Don okay yes so what we're doing is
we're we're gonna cool it on school for
a second so that we can come up with a
plan and tonight I want you in your
journal to go okay here's what I want to
accomplish I want to you want to get out
of debt we know that you're wondering
about the car so that's what I want you
to write you know just scribble it out
debt okay car cars first think when
we're gonna think we're gonna get out of
this car we need to find out if you're
writing it down now find out what the
car is worth because we want to make
sure that we can sell it do we need to
get a little loan to cover the
difference and get out of that car and
then get just a little beater car cash
great that eliminates 30k of debt and
you know what I mean by a beater two
thousand three thousand five thousand
dollar car all right yeah the next thing
we're thinking about is income we're not
making enough income and the income we
have is not steady so we need to be
thinking about okay you've got a skill
set let's get some full-time numbers
going because once you get those
full-time numbers going we can start
smashing this debt and we can start
making a plan to save for school and the
faster that we can save for school the
faster you can go to school and in the
meantime I want you to start making a
plan for school and we're just writing
this down what comes first what comes
second what comes third and the school
thing right now John you can tell me if
you think I'm wrong I think right now
school is third
because you have a way that you can earn
money it's something you're good at at
some point you you enjoyed it what
school are you going to
West Los Angeles College okay
um is this for your undergrad degree
yeah I originally got my associates in
Psychology so I'm starting back to get
an associate to transfer in kinesiology
to get the bachelor's to get accepted to
the Physical Therapy Program okay so
here's what I want you to do
um I had both my knees done two summers
ago and my physical therapist was
incredible
that's awesome guess where she went to
school
where I have no idea because I didn't
care
okay when you are paying for college
well you're paying for college with cash
you go for the free option you go for
the cheap option you go for the best
option for your for your buck and so
like Jade said I think she's right I
think it's number three and I think you
spend some time shopping shopping
shopping
and find a great education option that's
going to be that's going to fit your
budget Don thank you for the call look
you're on the right track you just need
to pull back a little bit and start
doing it the right way and that's just
thing one thing two thing three in order
of importance making sure that you're
doing this thing without a sense of debt